create that three onone and boiler I
don't think he was expecting it to come
back to him Bard now Main Street he
scores it's
[Applause]
over Conor Bard's second goal of the
game he bookends this
one a first period ice breaker and an
overtime game
winner and another solid celebration
afterward turns to the
crowd big smile for Conor Bard what a
rush up the ice all by himself splits
the two players and beats one of the
best goal Tenders in the league glove
side the deception the
speed unbelievable drag
release right there he just gets it on
the toe it might have taken a little
redirection off the stick and gets by
huk love that big smile for Conor
Bard it's over it's
over what an effort oh my gosh what an
effort you know again it it was
consistency tears of joy wow Conor
bringing the fans of tears at 18 won't
be the last
[Applause]
time